there's nothing wrong like oh my gosh
yeah I think this is why women shouldn't
run the world oh my God I don't get what
you guys mean by that book because women
because only a man like that could be
championed by a woman a man like that
wouldn't be championed by a man the
reason I would take
um what you said earlier is Be A
Champion is because you said it's so
good to see like a feminine gay guy in
the media yeah um so that to me was
championing that and like kind of
pushing it I don't think you did it
intentionally yeah I did it yeah yeah I
feel like you guys took it no no I I'm
saying the only reason I'm pointing it
out is because I think there's a lot of
subconscious things in society that we
don't really realize as women and like
once you see it you can't unsee it
um like an example this isn't
necessarily the same example but I think
of as like when we say
um a man knocked her up it's like that's
a way we subconsciously put the blame on
the man even though it takes two to
tango yeah yeah yeah yeah
and you didn't knock yourself up whereas
we whereas we speak on the show all the
time if a woman gets pregnant it's all
on her
actually I decided to change my stance
slightly I I will give I will give men
five percent blame
I'll take I'll say women 95 but like I
mean I mean pregnancy yeah yeah I feel
like yeah I feel like um I used to say
that it was 100 the woman's fault
because we have 41 forms of birth
control you can require them and you
sleep with rare condom you also can get
an abortion I mean I the list goes on
and on and on um you also have
abstinence you also you know
where men you know they just have
condoms and even if they do that they
could steal they could be stolen and
like vasectomy is but you know that they
also may not be reversible in some cases
so it's like do you really want to risk
that so because of that I used to say a
hundred percent on women but I decided
recently I was like you know what the
more I talked about some of y'all be
wilding in these streets I'm gonna I'm
gonna give you five percent plus I'm I'm
gonna say it might even be more than
that I just think that men should
protect their sperm right I think all
men should protect their sperm however
I've always said to women there's a
bunch of Reckless men out there girl oh
yeah you know there's a bunch of
Reckless men and some men aren't going
to protect their sperm and for those men
that aren't going to protect it you need
to protect yourself I'll give it
60 40. in favor of here women okay
because like as a man like
obviously as you get older
and you start to Value yourself a bit
more now I'm just like a bit of at the
age of my life where like you are I'm
protecting my sperm and things of that
nature so when I do that as a man it's
really hard to get anyone pregnant right
it's really hard
um
so
you have to take some accountability
because like if you if you allow if you
give 95 percent of the women you're
leaving it in their hands and I feel
like that's not smart I feel like it is
in our hands it is but it shouldn't be
left in your hand from a man's
perspective so that's why I say
like will you give me okay what about 30
on men 70 women yeah I'd say okay
I'm mistake to five but I don't want to
see if I can move you I could say 30.
because like you know it is it is
again to see who's more to blame yeah
yeah but when you say to blame in what
sense like okay I just think women have
a complete power when it comes to
reproduction yeah like we have 41 forms
of birth control we have abortion
especially in the UK you can get it up
to freaking six months which to me to me
yeah and it's free it's on the
government so your tax dollars are
paying for that
um on top of that we we have the choice
to give up a kid for adoption there's
cases in the U.S where the dad actually
wanted the child and the mom still gave
it up for adoption and he had no rights
in that right even if we have the kid we
can get child support from the dad even
if we get married we can leave and take
half
um and I think in the UK it's between 13
and 21 percent wait for child support
which isn't as high in the U.S where it
can be up to 50 like 25 percent per kid
but it's still you're still getting it
checked so like no matter what we choose
we're bailed out of every single
decision and we're men it's like the
only choice you have is to wear a condom
or not wear a condom so when we have all
this Choice like how can I say like with
more power comes more responsibility so
if we have more power then we have to
take more of the responsibility but
honestly like
so some of you guys I've heard had some
guys on the show yep
some of them are wow that I'm like you
don't even you don't even pull with
girls you don't know like yeah I'm like
all right five percent we're giveness I
remember what was the last what was the
guy's name you had Louie you had Louie
and you had drunk Justin
oh yeah and they're telling me and he
was saying that he's had like so many
he's got so many women pregnant and
um he's had like all of them had
abortions yeah
oh Justin's like isn't his 20s right
isn't his 20s I believe I there's
there's someone I know that said
there's someone I know that said that he
wouldn't pull out with University girls
because he's like oh they have something
to lose they don't want to get pregnant
and I'm like you know what that's
actually a mindset that it makes sense
because I feel like for me for me the
older I get the more I know like no
the women are gonna keep the baby like
when you're young you're like oh my God
you don't want to get pregnant you don't
want to disappoint your parent but as
you get older you're like if you're
taking risks like that do you really
think she's gonna get rid of the child
to be fair the numbers would back it up
a little bit what he's saying women that
make over forty seven thousand dollars
per year abort one out of three of their
babies where women below the poverty
line only abort eight percent so he's
kind of right but like do you really
this is why I gave five percent back so
I was like you know what that's that's
wild Reckless so you think that younger
women are less likely to want to have a
baby is what you're saying yeah because
you're younger and obviously you don't
want to bring that news to your parent
right and then you're still thinking
about your life and all that but as you
get older and your clocks start ticking
and you're gonna start thinking well if
I get rid of it now when am I gonna get
another one I thought I feel like I
always had an older friend who was like
he doesn't sleep with women with like
two or more kids because it's like
whatever I have another one like what's
one more gonna do today
it does make sense I was like yeah that
actually doesn't make sense so yeah wow
it's crazy but it's like
sorry what's my next question sorry one
second
yeah I don't I don't prescribe this I
would just like to like say now I don't
I don't be careful I'll be the best type
of approval on that
um yeah this is not don't don't yeah
when it comes to respect and masculinity
um
in each everyone's life here where you
were you grown with a masculine figure
in your life that you respected
like that but also my granddad as well
my grandfather on my dad's side was a
very masculine guy he was in the World
War II he was a fighter pilot you know
he's an RAF and all that and um he was
an actually
they unfortunately my grandparents died
when they were I mean they were sort of
at 60. so quite young really but um
their relationship actually was very
the sort of the old school kind of thing
as many
as many I was just ban
touched on
at least consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible